hi in this video i'm going to talk about
gal for ua system in drosophila so gal
for ua system in drosophila could be
used to overexpress or knock down a
particular gene in a tissue specific
manner
so this system is very useful in
genetics or cell biology research
because if we want to understand a role
of a protein inside a cell and which is
not yet characterized so what we can do
we can first knock down the protein and
in absence of that protein we can see
what are the phenotypic changes or what
changes occurring in the cell
so that is why we need to knock down or
sometimes we need to over express a
particular gene in tissue specific
manner
that is why gal for ua system is very
important and by using this system we
can easily knock down or over express a
particular gene in tissue specific
manner so let's see how it happens so we
have basically
two sets of flies two lines of flies one
line is called the driver line and
another line is responder line as the
name suggests the driver line would
drive expression of some something and
the responder line would respond to the
driver and it would
express our gene
or express our knockdown construct so
these driver line basically have gal4
under our tissue specific promoter
so this gal4 gene is actually
under our tissue specific promoter
inside this fly in this driver fly
so gal4 would be produced in a tissue
specific manner so for instance if in
this fly
gal4 is under a tissue-specific promoter
of neuron then in this particular fly
gal4 would be produced only inside the
neuron
not any place else in the body and in
the responded line what would happen the
gene of gene or
the rna construct it would be under the
control of uas so uas stands for
upstream activation sequence and gal4 is
basically our transcription factor and
gal4
would actually sit on the us and drive
the expression so when we cross this
driver line and the responder line in
the f1 generation inside that f1
generation fly
the gal4 could be produced in a tissue
specific manner and can sit on
us
region and can drive expression of the
gene or the rna construct so ultimate
result would be expression or knockdown
of that target gene in a tissue specific
manner
so now if we want to talk about
knockdown so let's see what is the
knockdown construct and actually what is
uh the idea behind gal4 driver line so
the gal4 driver line
these particular flies are transgenic
flies means they have
transgene have gene from other organisms
so what gene these driver fly have from
other organisms so this gal4 gene is not
endogenous to drosophila drosophila
doesn't have gal4 gene in fact east
required this gal4 gene for their
galactus metabolism
so
these galford gene is actually cloned
under a tissue-specific promoter
and put inside these driver flies by a p
element vector which can actually get
integrated inside the chromosome of this
driver line and produce this driver line
and again
if we talk about the responder line so
here we have said that
under the u.s control we either have a
gene
to be over expressed or a rnai construct
and now we would look
what is the rnai construct
so say for instance we want to knock
down
a protein
called protein
a
so now what we would do we would clone
some part of the protein a
in this direction
and then
leave a spacer or uh
leave a spacer region or linker region
then we would clone that particular
segment of that gene in an opposite
fashion and the entire thing would be in
a uas control
under us control and now this whole
construct would be
inserted into a p element vector and
this whole p element vector would be
inserted
into this responder line
uh
into the jar line of this responder so
that
when this responder line develops
now these construct get integrated into
its genome so the responder line would
express uas
under gene rnai us and the gene rnai
would be downstream to us
but the point to be remembered is that
in this responder line
only in this responder line the gene or
the rnai construct
is not active because
there is a upstream activation sequence
but there is no driver to drive the
expression of this particular
rnai and again in the gal4
the knock down doesn't take place or the
over expression doesn't take place
because
the
construct is not present but there is a
driver so when we cross these twos
one driver and one responder then what
happens
the gal for driver and the responder
line that means the upstream activation
sequence containing the knock down or
the over expression contra
construct
comes into
one fly and now
it could be expressed
with the help of gal4
so now as we know about gal4
let's look in a bit more details about
uh how gal4 works and how galford
mediated knockdown gal for mediated
tissue specific knockdown could be
performed
so
here i am zooming into the f1 fly f1
progeny fly
and
say for instance in this f1 fly the
particular
gene
for the particular gene for protein a is
knocked down by our so called knock down
construct
so if we zoom into this fly
so here is the neuron of that particular
fly
and now if we
further zoom into more details we would
see it's a neuron
so inside the neuron what happens
so inside the neuron
we have
from a particular chromosome gal4 is
expressed
and gal4 would drive the expression of
gene a rnai so gal4 would actually
drive the expression of rnai construct
and
this i have drawn in the cytoplasm
region but
just to for visual simplicity but it
actually happens inside the nucleus so
gal4 inside the neuron
is produced and gal4 actually expresses
the rnai construct and now we would see
after expression of that so-called
knock-down or rnai construct what
actually happens
the so-called rnai or knockdown
construct is actually
this construct so when this construct is
expressed inside the neuron it would
produce a hairpin rna double-stranded
hairpin rna and
there is a protein called dicer dicer is
actually
rna's three-family protein and it can
actually cleave
the double-stranded rna and produce
single stranded rna so it would produce
two type of single strand rna one is
called the guide in this red it is
called the guide strand and this black
one is called
the passenger strand so this guide
strand would actually perform the
further steps in the knockdown
so the guide stand would get associated
with another
huge protein complex called risk
rnai silencing complex so this
particular protein complex shown in
black is actually essential for
rnai mediated knock down or silencing of
the gene
remember here the gene silencing is
actually taking place in the
mrna level so now what happens
these guide strand along with
these
risk
would go
and
we have to remember that from the
nucleus the normal expression of
protein a
so protein
of so the normal expression of protein a
is taking place from the genome so the
mrna for protein a is produced
shown in green
one side
these dicer mediated uh
a pathway is happening and other side
the normal cell central dogma is
producing the protein a
and what happens
the protein a
the protein is mrna the mrna that is
responsible for production of protein a
is actually complementary to this guide
strand
so that is why these mrna for protein a
is get a getting associated with the
guide stand and the risk that rnai
silencing complex further additional
proteins called argonaut proteins are
getting associated with it and after
association of all these things
the whole complex would be cleaved and
chopped off so the host mrna that would
produce protein a
would be chopped off
and
now we won't get any mrna or we won't
get any protein a
so we would say that our protein a is
actually knocked down in a tissue
specific manner moreover we can say that
our protein a is actually knocked down
in a neuron specific manner
now if we talk about a little bit about
what are the neuronal drivers so
neuronal driver popular neuronal driver
is elav you love gal4 so when we
use a loft
gal for driver
and we put some uh
knock down construct in another
responder line and we cross them two
then what happened
ultimately the gal4 drives the
expression of the
rnai construct and the rnai construct by
its dicer mediated pathway would produce
the rnai silencing complex that would
ultimately silence the host
mrna of protein a in this way we can
knock down that means we can stop the
expression or reduce the expression of
protein a in a significant manner in a
tissue-specific manner
so
for understanding the role of protein a
which i earlier said is not
characterized and it is not
characterized that what role protein a
plays in the neuron that is why we are
knocking down protein a in the neuron
and we would see in absence of neuron
what changes happens in the neuron
so
if in absence of protein a that means in
the knockdown condition protein a gives
any type of phenotype
a protein
in absence of protein a if neuron gives
any type of phenotype then we would say
protein a had particular role in neuron
and we would further analyze that is why
the ua's gal for system in drosophila is
very important for initial genetic
steps so
these us gal4 system could be used in
two particular cases one is over
expression and one is knocked down so if
we talk about over expression instead of
this knocked down construct we would
have a over expression construct that
mean the gene that to be over expressed
would be under the uas control
and now it could be over expressed in a
tissue specific manner
and with this particular gal for ua
system we can even screen we can design
a genetic screen a genome-wide genetic
screen to particularly knock down
several proteins
gene of several proteins and see in
absence of that protein what are the
phenotypes in this way we can use this
particular genetic tool that means gal
for us system
to understand the role of new proteins
and to find the role of new proteins
hope this video helps you hope you
enjoyed
please like and subscribe thank you